[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute
mitmietri Serin in allen einen schönen
guten Abend Norbert Lehmann ist bei mir
und hat die fußballnachlesung geprägt
Champions League schönen guten Abend
auch von mir und das sind die Themen des
Tages
China als
friedensstifter-chef Diplomat one
verspricht in Moskau sein Land werde
eine konstruktive Rolle in der
ukraine-krise spielen
Neuanfang in Trümmern immer deutlicher
zeigt sich im Erdbebengebiet wie schwer
Hilfe und wieder Aufbau sind wenn fast
alles improvisiert werden muss
und politgaudi auf bayrisch
Ministerpräsident Söder poltert zum
Aschermittwoch gegen die Berliner Ampel
und bekommt contra von Rot-Grün Geld
[Musik]
Chinas Rolle im ukraine-krieg ist das
Thema dieser Tage wie eng ist der
Schulterschluss mit Russland tatsächlich
und wie soll die groß angekündigte
Friedensinitiative von staatschefski
Aussehen Chinas Chef Außenpolitiker
wangier war heute bei Präsident Putin er
lobte die Beziehungen zwischen beiden
Ländern und betonte ganz diplomatisch
dass sie sich nicht gegen Dritte richten
würden was man so oder so interpretieren
kann Nina niedergal über diplomatische
drahtseilakte im kremme
Russland und China sind eng
zusammengerückt diese Botschaft will
Wladimir Putin wohl senden als er den
obersten chinesischen Außenpolitiker
empfängt keins sind sie vor allem als
Kontrahenten der USA
die umfassende strategische
Partnerschaft zwischen China und
Russland richtet sich niemals gegen
Dritte und wird natürlich nicht durch
Einmischungen und Provokationen Dritter
beeinträchtigt wir werden keinem Zwang
oder Druck Dritter nachgeben mit Blick
auf den Ukraine Krieg sagte er China
wolle eine aktivere Rolle bei einer
Lösung einnehmen
später
natürlich warten wir auf einen Besuch
des chinesischen Staatspräsidenten
in Moskau kurz bevor sich der Ukraine
Krieg zum ersten Mal jährt wird gefeiert
im Luschniki-Stadion haben zehntausende
bei Minusgraden aus Putins Auftritt
dauert dann gerade mal knapp fünf
Minuten
[Musik]
Patriotismus perfekt inszeniert einige
der Tickets wurden an Unis und in
Betrieben verteilt
man hat mich hierher geschickt und da
bin ich halt gefahren
mir wurde es auf der Arbeit
vorgeschlagen da habe ich zugestimmt ich
wollte mir das hier selbst mal ansehen
in unmittelbarer Nähe wurde eigens ein
Flugabwehrsystem installiert ein Symbol
für die gefühlte Bedrohung aus dem
Westen vor der Putin warnt dem Konflikt
kann sich auch China nicht entziehen
China sieht das Putin diesen Krieg
verliert und macht sich darüber Sorgen
weil der Hauptgegner Chinas doch die
Vereinigten Staaten sind und in diesem
Moment ist die Frage ob China bereit ist
sich diesem Konflikt direkt
anzuschließen und Waffen zu liefern
solche Annahmen wurden vom
US-Außenminister Anthony blinken
geäußert
wangi aber gab sich heute eher als
Konfliktlöser auch beim Treffen mit
Russlands Außenminister Sergej Nachbar
Chinas Oberst im Außenpolitiker standen
in Moskau alle Türen offen Russland
umgarn seine Nachbarn ist auf dessen
wahren Lieferungen und ölkäufe
angewiesen mehr denn je dabei muss
Moskau aufpassen nicht zu dem zu werden
was es nie sein wollte Pekings kleiner
Bruder
ob bei Russlands diplomatischer
offensiver auch der Friedensplan zur
Sprache kam den Peking wohl bald
vorstellen will das blieb unklar
Russlands Angriffskrieg auch Thema
gleich um halb acht bei heute live im
Fokus die Frage steht Russland noch
hinter Putin zu sehen in der ZDF heute
App und auf unseren Social Media Kanälen
seit Beginn des russischen
Angriffskrieges machen sich die
östlichen NATO-Staaten große Sorgen es
gibt dort Befürchtungen Russland könnte
auch gegen sie militärisch vorgehen und
genau darum hat sich US-Präsident beiden
bei seinem polenbesuch mit Vertretern
der östlichen Nato-Partner getroffen er
sprach von einer heiligen Verpflichtung
die die USA eingegangen sein jeder
Zentimeter des nato-gebietes würde
verteidigt
fragen wir Mr teven in Warschau der das
mitverfolgt hat Solidarität und
Selbstvergewisserung stehen im
Vordergrund aber sind denn die östlichen
Nato-Partner dabei wirklich auf einer
Linie
nach außen hin ja sie haben eine
gemeinsame Erklärung verabschiedet in
der sie die russische Invasion
schafeurteilen und Russland als
Bedrohung für die transatlantische
Sicherheit bezeichnet dabei saßen mit am
Tisch Bulgarien und Ungarn die ja in den
vergangenen Monaten hin und wieder
kritisiert haben das ist eine
Waffenhilfe an die Ukraine gibt Ungarn
hier vertreten durch den Präsidenten
Nowak hat ja einen Premierminister
Viktor Orban der sich selber als Freund
von Wladimir Putin bezeichnet und sein
Land als
illiberale Demokratie und wohl deshalb
hat Joe beide auch hier appelliert an
alle sie seien die Frontlinie in der
Verteidigung der kollektiven
Verteidigung auch der Verteidigung von
Werten und der Demokratie am Ende haben
da alle zugestimmt und auch Ungarn hat
die Erklärung und unterzeichnet vielen
Dank nach Warschau wissen
nach dem Todesurteil gegen einen
deutsch-irana reagiert die
Bundesregierung mit der Ausweisung
zweier iranischer Diplomaten sie wurden
zu unerwünschten Personen erklärt und
aufgefordert Deutschland so schnell wie
möglich zu verlassen
Außenministerin bareborg forderte
Teheran auf das Todesurteil gegen
Jumpsuit Charmed zu widerrufen und ihm
ein faires und rechtsstaatliches
Berufungsverfahren zu ermöglichen
jetzt zur Erdbebenkatastrophe in der
Türkei und Syrien da hat Deutschland
nach Angaben der Bundesregierung bislang
rund 500 Zelte fast 350 Generatoren und
200 Beatmungsgeräte in die Türkei
geliefert die Not der Menschen dort ist
nach wie vor E-Mails in der
Katastrophenregion sind etwa 1,5
Millionen obdachlos der improvisierte
Alltag schwierig berichtet unsere
reporterin Anne Brühl und sie war für
uns im türkischen adiaman
das Gebäude der Provinzregierungen
adiamant steht noch mitten im
erdbebenchaos von hier aus koordinieren
sie Hilfe soweit das irgendwie geht in
einer Stadt deren Zentrum fast völlig
zerstört und unbewohnbar ist
wir sind für die Säuberung des
gouverneursamts zuständig wir machen
alles sauber wir schleppen die Trümmer
raus säubern die Zimmer
auf der anderen Straßenseite Teilen
freiwillige vom Roten Halbmond warmes
Essen und Obst aus für diejenigen die
alles verloren haben
Hygieneprodukte gebraucht und Kekse und
natürlich Babynahrung Wasser Brei solche
Dinge
ist vor dem Krieg in ihrer Heimat in die
Türkei geflüchtet
wir brauchen alles uns geht es nicht gut
wir haben keinen Pass uns geht es nicht
gut
weiter leben in adiaman inmitten einer
Trümmerwüste
einzelne Zelte stehen in den Straßen
weil die Menschen nicht fort wollen
viele hat das bebentraumatisiert wir
haben mitbekommen die gegenüber zwei
Häuser eingestürzt sind wir haben
Verwandte verloren so ist es
die Häuser die nicht eingestürzt sind
werden jetzt alle überprüft erst wenn
klar ist dass sie sicher sind dürfen die
Überlebenden von adiaman wieder nach
Hause
viele Millionen Menschen sind und
bleiben von den Erdbeben betroffen das
Aktionsbündnis Katastrophenhilfe hilft
vor Ort sie könne das unterstützen die
IBAN lautet
de65-100 400
600-100-40000 Stichwort ZDF Erdbeben
Türkei Syrien mehr finden sie auf
spenden.zdf.de und auf dem ZDF Text 89.0
jetzt sind den Namen Osten bei einer
Razzia der israelischen Armee Invest
jordanland sind laut palästinensischen
Angaben mindestens zehn Menschen getötet
worden mehr als 100 wurden verletzt das
Militär teilte mit es habe drei
Terrorverdächtige festnehmen wollen
dabei sein die Soldaten beschossen
worden und hätten zurückgeschossen die
Lage in Israel und den Palästinenser
Gebieten seit langem angespannt seit
Jahresbeginn kamen mindestens 9 Israelis
und 50 Palästinenser ums Leben
es ist ein Teilerfolg für die AFD vor
dem Bundesverfassungsgericht schon lange
fordert die ihr nahestehende die
siderius erasmus-stiftung sowie andere
parteinahe Stiftungen auch Millionen
Gelder aus dem Bundeshaushalt zu
bekommen die Partei klagte und das
Bundesverfassungsgericht gab ihr heute
teilweise Recht fordert aber
gleichzeitig eine gesetzliche Regelung
Samuel Kirch berichtet
die diese Darius erasmus-stiftung lädt
ein hier zur Diskussion über
Wirtschaftspolitik mehr Seminare wie
dieses würde die stiftungsvorsitzende
Erika Steinbach gerne veranstalten wir
wollen die geistigen Grundlagen für eine
politische und auch für eine ethische
Erneuerung unseres Landes liegen
Erneuerung von Rechtsaußen dafür fordert
die AFD Zuschüsse für ihre Stiftung vom
Staat die anderen Parteien verhindern
eine Förderung bislang ohne ausreichende
Gesetzesgrundlage sagt heute das
Bundesverfassungsgericht
bei der staatlichen Förderung der Partei
nahen Stiftungen handelt es sich um eine
für die Ausgestaltung unserer
demokratischen Ordnung wesentliche Frage
die der Regelung durch ein eigenes
Gesetz Bedarf welche Stiftung wie viel
Geld erhält bislang liegt das der
Haushaltsausschuss des Bundestages fest
diese Vergabepraxis ist in Karlsruhe
Richterinnen und Richtern nicht
transparent genug die AFD zufrieden mit
dem Urteil
660 Millionen Euro im Jahr können jetzt
nicht mehr in irgendwelchen
stiftungsgesprächen im Hinterzimmer
vergeben werden sondern müssen ganz
klaren gesetzlichen Regelungen folgen
das ist ein sehr kleiner Sieg für die
AFD und die die seriös erasmus-stiftung
weil damit nicht gesagt ist das
automatisch Ansprüche bestehen das
einzige was Karlsruhe heute gesagt hat
ist es muss ein Gesetz her der Ball
liegt nun also beim Gesetzgeber er muss
die Voraussetzungen wann eine politische
Stiftung gefördert werden kann und war
nicht ganz genau regeln das Urteil macht
aber auch deutlich
Verfassungsfeinde muss der Steuerzahler
nicht finanzieren der Gesetzgeber kann
Stiftungen die sich gegen die
freiheitlich demokratische Grundordnung
richten von einer Förderung ausschließen
die Verfassungstreue der afd-stiftung
deren Partei vom Verfassungsschutz
beobachtet wird hat das Gericht heute
nicht bewertet
ob es künftig Steuermillionen gibt für
politische Bildung im Sinne der AFD das
wird sich nach einem neuen
Stiftungsgesetz richten
im Tarifstreit des öffentlichen Dienstes
von Bund und Kommunen wird wieder
verhandelt in Potsdam ging es da in die
zweite Runde begleitet von weiteren
Warnstreiks die Gewerkschaft Verdi und
der Beamtenbund drohen die Streiks
auszuweiten sie fordern ein Einkommens
Plus von 10,5% mindestens aber 500 € pro
Monat bei einer Laufzeit von 12 Monaten
die Arbeitgeberseite hat bislang kein
Angebot vorgelegt
eigentlich ist der politische
Aschermittwoch wieder Karneval man muss
ihn schon mögen um ihn wirklich schätzen
zu können Politik im Bierzelt deftige
Parolen Rhetorik mit dem Dampfhammer
kann funktionieren muss aber nicht
Alexander Pool war mittendrin
[Applaus]
er hat geliefert im Jahr der bayerischen
Landtagswahl gibt Markus Söder den
csu-anhängern wonach sie sich
unüberhörbar gesehen haben Politik zum
Mitgrölen die Lage der Welt der Ukraine
Krieg Randnotizen der CSU-Chef Holz
anderthalb Stunden lang in Richtung
Ampel die Ampel ist die schlechteste
Bundesregierung die Deutschland je hatte
liebe Freunde die gender Pflicht in
bayerischen Schulen und Hochschulen
lehnen wir ab
in Frankfurt betont SPD-Chef Lars
Klingbeil die Bundesregierung unter
Kanzler Scholz gebe dem Land
Orientierung und er nimmt die
Steilvorlage der CSU gerne auf also
Krieg Inflation
Energiekrise Corona das beschäftigt uns
schon alles aber Markus Söder hat jetzt
identifiziert die letzten Tage was
wirklich bedrohlich ist dass Gendern
nicht nur in der Klimapolitik habe die
Union in 16 merkeljahren entscheidende
Reformen verschleppt kritisiert die
Grünen Vorsitzende Ricarda lang im
niederbayerischen Landshut wenn ich
Karren in die Scheiße geritten habe und
dann andere den für mich rauszieht dann
habe ich doch eine Entscheidung ob ich
entweder meckernd am Rand stehe oder ob
ich endlich auch selbst Teil der Lösung
wäre eine einheitliche Front bilden die
ampelparteien heute nicht
FDP-Chef Christian Lindner plädiert
erneut für einen Ausbau bestehende
Autobahnen und appelliert an die Grünen
die Grünen wollen Tempo machen bei den
Schulden und Bremsen beim Verkehr
umgekehrt wäre besser nicht nur in
Bayern stehen in diesem Jahr
Landtagswahlen an der heutige Tag ein
erster Vorgeschmack
jetzt der Blick zur Berlinale der
vermessene Mensch heißt ein Film der
heute abend Premiere feiert es geht um
den Völkermord an den Herero und Nama im
heutigen Namibia ein Kapitel deutscher
Kolonialgeschichte das lange verdrängt
wurde politische aufgeladen und
hochaktuell über Film und Premiere jetzt
Stefan Merseburger
Weltpremiere auf der Berlinale am
Nachmittag Regisseur Lars krumme und
sein Team präsentieren der vermessene
Mensch es geht um den wohl finstersten
Teil der deutschen Kolonialgeschichte
wie Sie sehen ist der Kopf des weißen
Mannes doch beträchtlich größer als
dieser hier der Kopf eines Sand auch
Buschmann genannt auf einer sogenannten
völkerschau in Berlin trifft eine
Ethnologe auf eine Delegation von Herero
aus Deutsch Südwestafrika dem heutigen
Namibia erlernt die Dolmetscherin kennen
droht in ein Krieg bei euch
der Ethnologe reiste die Kolonie und
wird Zeuge des Völkermordes an Herero
und Nama etwa 80.000 Menschen sterben
wir können nur über unsere Geschichte
erzählen und die ist nun mal sehr düster
und und ist eben im wahrsten Sinne des
Wortes eine Täterperspektive denn Europa
hat sich in keinem dieser kolonialen
Kontext irgendwie mit Ruhm besudeln
jeder Student Görlitz Charlene jasama
spielt die Übersetzerin sie ist aus
Namibia und Herero also selbst betroffen
um die sogenannte Überlegenheit der
weißen Rasse zu beweisen plündert der
Ethnologe Gräber und sammelt Schädel
ernster unsere Vorfahren sind uns sehr
wichtig sie müssen Frieden und Ruhe in
Würde finden
das kann nicht geschehen bevor wir diese
Dinge zurückbekommen
noch heute Lagern tausende Schädel in
die Depots deutscher Museen der
vermessene Mensch eine zdf-co-produktion
erzählt ein ebenso unrühmliches wie
wichtiges Kapitel deutsche Geschichte
wir machen als Schnitt sind beim Sport
bei der Fußball Champions League und
Norbert die letzten Achtelfinalspiele
stehen an und da muss Leipzig bei
Manchester City rein ja und da weiß er
Trainer Marco Rose ganz genau was ihn da
erwartet eine Top-Mannschaft der
Tabellenzweite in England mit einem Top
Trainer Taktikfuchs Bett Guardiola und
ein top top Torjäger in Bestform oerling
Holland 32 Tore in 31 City spielen
ein jubelnder order natürlich auch in
der Champions League ein gewohntes Bild
beim neuen Verein fünf Tore bereits in
der Königsklasse sein extremer freut
sich trotzdem auf das Wiedersehen ich
sehe uns bereit und für uns ist einfach
große Vorfreude wir wollen alle Aufgaben
die sich uns stellen und das werden eine
Menge
örling ist eine davon
versuchen zu lösen
Leipzigs top Stürmer Christopher droht
auszufallen muskuläre Probleme nach
seinem Camping am Samstag cities Trainer
pep Guardiola der auf Kevin de Bruyne
verzichten muss warnt dennoch ja nur der
Qualität darf das ich kenne ihre
Qualitäten es werden zwei sehr harte
Spiele wir müssen unsere Emotionen
kontrollieren und einfach unsere
Leistung bringen
der Gast aus der Premier League also
selbstbewusst und nicht nur wegen allen
der Favorit in diesem Achtelfinale
Frankfurt gestern Abend daheim mit einer
Hinspiel-Niederlage gegen Neapel Viktor
Siemens brachte den italienischen
Tabellen ersten in der 40 minute in
Führung in der zweiten Halbzeit erst die
rote Karte für Eintracht Stürmer
kolumani er fehlt dem Rückspiel und
sieben Minuten später dann Giovanni di
Lorenzo zum 022 entstand
ja noch viel schlimmer erwischte es
Jürgen Klopp mit Liverpool 2:5
heimklatsche gegen Real Madrid alle Tore
alle Höhepunkte der Achtelfinal
Hinspiele von gestern und heute zu sehen
bei uns in Sportstudio Champions League
um 23 Uhr
keine Sperre für bayerntrainer
nagelsmann nach seinem verbalen
Ausraster beim Bundesligaspiel am
Samstag verurteilte ihn das
DFB-Sportgericht lediglich zu einer
50.000 € Geldbuße
heute startet der nordischen Ski-WM im
slowenischen Planitzer und gestern Abend
die farbenfrohe Eröffnungsfeier mit den
deutschen Fahnenträgern
Juniorenweltmeisterin Natalie Armbruster
und Olympiasieger Vinzenz Geiger beide
Nordische Kombination dazu kommen noch
die Wettbewerbe im Skispringen und im
Langlauf
und die ersten wärmedaillen die gibt es
morgen bei uns zu sehen ZDF ab 14 15
Dankeschön Norbert wir hätten noch die
Lottozahlen am Mittwoch für sie und die
gehen so vier sechs neun 27 44 46 und
die Superzahl lautet 8 weitere
Gewinnzahlen auf lotto.zdf.de und auf
der ZDF Textseite 557
beim Wetter geht es mit östern Tally
gleich um 9 Uhr Regen
mein Programm Tipp für 21:45 Uhr das
heute journal mit Dunja Hayali wir vom
19 Uhr heute Team sagen danke fürs
zuschauen wir sehen uns morgen wieder
ihnen allen noch einen schönen und
entspannten Abend
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter ja etwas Regen
erwartet uns morgen im Tagesverlauf der
von West nach Ost sich durchsetzt ja und
am Abend dann sogar im Osten ankommt und
dann die nächsten Tage gibt es dann
einen Wintereinbruch light denn von
Norden her kommt die Kaltluft voran und
so wird es zum Wochenende deutlich
kälter der kommende nachts erst einmal
Regen von Westen her ganz im Osten
bleibt es trocken nach Südosten bildet
sich Nebel bei tiefsten Temperaturen von
zwei Grad Richtung Berlin Brandenburg
und 8 Grad am Niederrhein morgen dann
der Regen der bis zur Mitte etwa
vorankommt zum Abend an den Osten
erreicht hier gibt es aber noch etwas
Sonnenschein vorher dass bei höchsten
Temperaturen von 6 Grad in
Schleswig-Holstein und 15 Grad im
Südwesten dort noch mal richtig Mels die
kommenden Tage da es wird nasser und
außerdem kommt Schnee dazu von Norden
her am Freitag vor allem in den
Mittelgebirgen bei zwei bis zwölf Grad
ja und man am Samstag schneit es
Richtung Erzgebirge länger und auch am
alpenrandsonntag dann spürbar kälter
damit ein schöner Abend